Insects are a common fear among humans.
Evolutionarily, certain bugs are notorious
for spreading disease and in some cases even
being deadly.
Arachnids like the Brown Recluse and Brazilian
Wandering Spider hold venoms that are extremely
painful or deadly in high enough dosages.
Wasps and Hornets exist to defend their territory
and sting anything that gets close to them.
Mosquitoes have been responsible for spreading
diseases throughout history - yellow fever,
malaria, zika virus, and West Nile virus to
name of a few.
However, what’s less commonly discussed
are ticks.
They are similar to mosquitos, they latch
onto mammals and consume their blood by use
of a thin needle like mouth.
They are also responsible for countless diseases,
the most infamous being Lyme Disease.
These animals are parasitic in nature and
depend on mammals like humans for sustenance.
Human beings are social creatures and because
of our behavior, it’s been made pretty easy
for us to make friends, find relationships,
connect with our parents, or do well in the
workplace.
The ability for humans to find these connections
so easily allowed us to become the dominant
species on Earth.
Without this ability, human beings would not
be in the place we are currently.
Today, you may have gone out with a few friends,
spoke to your loved ones, or said hi to someone
on the street.
Imagine if these attempts to continue human
connection were instead met with silence,
blank stares, and disgust.
Well in the world of the SCP Foundation, this
fantasy is a reality for a few unlucky people
who ran into some uncontained anomalies before
the SCP Foundation could properly intervene.
It was a mildly breezy summer day, perfect
for a picnic or relaxing outside with a refreshing
beverage.
The weather was ideal and Daniel Arnoldson
was up bright and early hoping to take full
advantage of it.
It had been weeks of what felt like an infinite
heatwave making long periods of daylight unbearable,
so Daniel and his wife, Eliza, were itching
to get a nice day outside, and now it came.
After going over some ideas, they decided
on taking a nice hike through the nearby trail
in the mountains.
They began packing their backpacks: bear spray,
granola, water, and rain clothes in case this
weather turned its back on the people who
were basking in its glory.
They also brought some picnic supplies for
when they reached the summit of the mountain.
The car ride to the hiking trail was uneventful,
but the couple was happy.
They were the epitome of high school sweethearts.
The two had been dating since their freshman
year of high school and it was practically
love at first sight.
Dan and Eliza were almost inseparable.
They spent every hour with each other and
never got bored of each other’s presence.
They went to every school dance together and
even wore matching outfits every time - Aww…how
cute right?
- There was always something to talk about,
always something to laugh about, and they
never even had a real argument.
They went to the same college to stay close,
and got married right after graduation.
It was meant to be, Dan and Eliza were seemingly
perfect together in every way.
And to be out of the house with bearable weather
was making them even more happy.
They arrived at the start of the trail and
began their trek in the beautiful weather.
It was long and it was tiring, but with each
other at their sides, they encouraged themselves
to finish it and have their picnic.
Eventually, they made it to the top.
Dan, who was more tired than Eliza, left picnic
set-up duties to her and took a seat in the
grass.
His exhaustion got the better of him, and
he laid down.
It seems the couple forgot one important item:
bug repellent.
I guess they’re not so perfect after all
huh?
As soon as Daniel laid himself onto the grass,
a small, almost invisible tick latched itself
onto the back of his neck.
He didn’t notice it, and sat up as soon
as the picnic mat was placed down and moved
onto it.
They shared a nice meal, and sat for some
time.
As the sun began to set, the couple made their
way back down the mountain and returned home,
now with their new, unknown visitor, the tick.
The next morning, something changed in Eliza.
It was a monday, so Daniel had to get up early
for work.
Normally, he’s met with a groggy kiss and
a sluggish “good morning” from his wife,
but this day, he didn’t get that.
Dan brushed it off.
“She was probably just tired from the hike.”
He thought to himself, and headed to work.
The day went by the same as most work days.
Putting in the hours, excited to get back
home to his lovely wife for a nice evening
of Netflix and chill.
But he returned to something he never expected
to see.
As he pulled into his driveway he saw all
of his belongings: shirts, pants, shoes, books,
pieces of technology, even the gifts he bought
for Eliza - all left in a heaping pile on
the pavement outside of their house.
He was appalled, his heart began to race as
questions flooded his mind.
“Did I do something wrong?”
“Did I say something hurtful?”
I thought she had a good time yesterday, what
happened?”
He frantically barged into the house and immediately
yelled for his wife: “Eliza!”
But there was no response.
“Eliza!” he cried again, but to no avail.
Either she wasn’t home or he was being completely
ignored.
He ventured through the many rooms of his
home, looking for any sign of his wife.
Dan found her in her office, and said her
name to her again.
“Eliza?”
No response.
She didn’t even look at him.
“What’s going on, Eliza?
Why aren’t you talking to me?”
He yelled at her.
No response.
He pushed Eliza’s desk out of the way and
stood in front of her, but was met with a
blank, forward facing stare.
Nothing.
She didn’t even seem to see him.
Daniel went to touch his wife’s shoulder
and upon contact, her face turned to disgust
and she recoiled, but she still didn’t look
at him.
For the next five hours, Daniel tried his
hardest to get the smallest amount of acknowledgement
from his wife, but all he was met with was
silence, blank stares, and a face of disgust
whenever he went to touch her.
Day turned to night as Daniel’s pleas to
his wife continued.
It went on for so long, that a nearby neighbor
called the police, and Daniel was arrested
and placed in a criminal psychiatric ward
for the time.
He stayed there for a few days, as police
interviewed Eliza.
They asked her a number of questions regarding
Daniel, but she didn’t even know who Daniel
was.
She was shown pictures of them together, but
there was no sign of recognition from her,
she couldn’t even see him in the pictures.
That is when the SCP Foundation agents embedded
in the local law enforcement sniffed out that
there was a potential anomaly involved in
this event.
The SCP Foundation agents wrangled oversight
away from the original police officers and
began their investigation.
They interviewed Daniel, where he told them
the story of the hike and about the day after
it.
The SCP Foundation researchers, still posing
as police and medical professionals, were
stumped.
What could cause such a loving couple to detach
from one another like that, and why was Eliza
acting as if she couldn’t even see Daniel?
After a medical examination, the tick Dan
had been bitten by during the hike was found
to be still attached to him.
It was removed, and Daniel was allowed to
go free from the psychiatric ward.
Sadly, Daniel went missing the next day.
The following note was found in a diary he
began writing in since the start of the event:
“All alone.
Always alone.
She couldn't see me, no matter what I did.
She couldn't care.
I thought we were happy.
Then one day, I come back home and all of
my stuff is out on the pavement, and when
I go inside she acts like I don't even exist.
I shout at her, and I shake her, but nothing
works.
She just walks around me like I'm not there.
I scream at her for hours.
Hours! and she just ignores me.
Every time I touch her she gets that disgusted
look on her face, like I'm some scum.
So I took it off forever.
She’s a backstabber and a liar.
She had it coming.
She got what she deserved.”
“Why didn't she just love me anymore?”
Daniel was just as confused as the SCP Foundation.
He lost his relationship, the love of his
life, for no reason, and now he can’t even
talk to her as he’s just met with silence
and a blank stare.
There was seemingly no answer, and the SCP
Foundation researchers were lost as to where
to start.
After a few days of scratching their heads,
researchers recalled the tick they removed
from Daniel’s neck.
As weird as entertaining a tick as the possible
culprit of a bad break up may seem - Remember,
this is the SCP Foundation and they have people
running around in there obsessed with the
idea of eating bread in hopes to poop out
toast because they think they’re a toaster
for 343’s sake!
Anyway…back to the tick.
The SCP Foundation began testing on it and
just as their hunch suggested, it turned out
that it was far from a common tick, it merely
resembled one.
The tick is now designated SCP-1655.
The Foundation also found something incredibly
peculiar, SCP-1655 does not follow the common
life cycle of a normal tick and it does not
require the normal sustenance a non-anomalous
tick of its species would need to survive.
They found the specimen to be extremely aggressive.
It will immediately target the nearest mammal,
whether it be a small animal or a full grown
human, SCP-1655 will latch itself onto their
body and begin drawing blood.
Given how dangerous this anomaly could be
if not properly contained within safe parameters,
the SCP Foundation assigned it to the Euclid
level of containment classes.
To ensure that SCP-1655 does not attach itself
to anyone of real importance at the SCP Foundation,
the following containment procedures were
devised.
SCP-1655 will be kept in a 5 x 5 x 5 cm plexiglass
container.
Importantly, any handling of SCP-1655 that
requires the opening of its container is to
be performed by D-class personnel only.
Guess that D does really stand for disposable,
huh.
While the Foundation suspected SCP-1655 as
being the culprit for the seemingly anomalous
effects that ended with Daniel and Eliza breaking
up, they needed to run some tests to be sure
that SCP-1655 was in fact the danger they
thought it was.
The first test began with a female tabby cat
and its kitten.
The kitten was placed in its own chamber with
SCP-1655.
In mere seconds, the tick latched onto the
young cat.
The kitten was then placed in the same testing
chamber as its mother and the mother cat no
longer acknowledged the kitten's existence.
The kitten meowed and cried for its mother’s
attention, however, no signs of recognition
were observed from the mother cat.
Later, the kitten's attempts to feed from
its mother were also met with resistance.
Because of this, the kitten was not able to
get enough sustenance, and thus starved to
death.
Researchers also found another odd feature
about SCP-1655.
A viscous, plasma-like substance appeared
in SCP-1655's blood sack.
Another test was conducted, this time on a
D-Class subject.
SCP-1655 was introduced to D-236.
After a period of a few hours, D-236 was asked
to contact his grandmother who raised him
from the age of 5 years old and on.
When on the phone, D-236’s grandmother did
not appear to recognize or even hear D-236’s
voice.
The overseeing researcher then took the phone
and began to question D-236’s grandmother
about D-236.
The old woman didn’t understand what the
researcher was talking about and had no memories
of D-236.
SCP Foundation researchers then assigned a
meeting between D-236 and his grandmother.
Upon meeting, the old woman showed no sign
of acknowledgement towards her grandson.
A researcher asked D-236 to touch his grandmother
on the arm.
He reached out toward her and she immediately
recoiled with a look of disdain on her face,
but looking right through him.
“What do you feel, ma’am” A researcher
asked the old woman.
“I don’t know – It’s like something
spooky or something.”
Over the period of the meeting, D-236 grew
extremely emotionally distressed and had to
be removed from the meeting location.
Notably, SCP-1655 appeared engorged following
this meeting, as if it was filled with blood.
From these tests, the SCP Foundation and its
researchers were able to devise the following
list of phenomena that will occur when SCP-1655
latches to a subject.
1.
Any living being the affected subject held
any degree of affection for will immediately
lose all memory of the subject's existence.
This includes minor interactions to life-long
relationships.
The people who once knew the victim will also
be unable to create or acquire any new memories
concerning the victim or anything surrounding
them.
2.
People who were once connected to the subject
will not be able to sense the victim of SCP-1655
in any manner no matter the circumstance.
However, any physical contact with the victim
of SCP-1655 will cause mild discomfort and
disgust.
If the physical contact is left for a prolonged
period of time, discomfort and disgust will
increase in intensity the longer contact is
held until the physical contact is removed.
3.
If the subject begins to feel affection for
any other living being, including animals
or other humans, they will also be affected
by SCP-1655 and its anomalous properties.
SCP Foundation researcher’s hypothesize
that SCP-1655 is able to extract information
from its victims.
In turn, SCP-1655 has the ability to alter
its effects thus allowing it to maintain complete
emotional isolation on its victims and, in
turn, feed on more of these negative emotions
that it causes its victims to have.
4.
The subject will ignore SCP-1655's existence.
Possibly the most important detail of the
SCP Foundation’s findings are about the
lingering effects of SCP-1655, even after
it was removed from a victim.
It was found that these effects of being unable
to create human connections remain permanent
well after removal, however, anyone the victim
is not affectionate towards is not affected
by SCP-1655’s effects, but if that connection
is made, the victim practically does not exist
to that person.
SCP Foundation researchers hypothesize that
the parasite keeps a mental link with its
victims.
It then continues to feed off of the negative
emotions the effects of its bite has placed
on the victim.
It makes sense why the SCP Foundation researchers
made such strict special containment procedures
for SCP-1655.
Something undetectable that completely and
mindlessly eliminates human connection is
extremely dangerous if it’s allowed to be
left uncontained.
The SCP Foundation researchers then began
testing on SCP-1655’s saliva and the fluid
it was putting into the bloodstream of its
victims.
Unfortunately, the tests were unable to identify
all of the different components.
There were, however, powerful depressant chemicals
and traces of hormones found that can negatively
affect the Hippocampus section of a victim’s
brain.
The hippocampus is the area of the brain located
in the temporal lobe.
It is responsible for learning and acts as
a storage unit for memory.
And SCP-1655 appears to extract memories from
its victim’s hippocampus using these unknown
hormones, causing the people surrounding the
victim to completely detach from them.
Could it be possible that SCP-1655 has telepathic
abilities?
While physiological examinations proved unable
to confirm how SCP-1655 uses the information
it retrieves from the Hippocampus to affect
others, it is extremely clear that it is actively
causing mental anguish to its subjects, most
likely in order to speed up its feeding process.
So it’s definitely clear that SCP-1655 feeds
off the turmoil it inflicts.
But the larger questions are why and how?
How did SCP-1655 develop these abilities?
Was it evolution?
Perhaps that is in fact the case here.
Or maybe it’s even simpler.
Maybe the tick lacked a sustainable food source
and just decided to feed on something else
that was easily accessible and just as sustainable:
Negativity.
So we have an entity that eliminates all human
bonds from the person it attaches to, then
it takes the pain and anguish a person feels
from their emotional connections disappearing
to sustain itself.
Very dangerous stuff here that, if left to
the wild, could cause unimaginable damage.
Imagine if this was left in a large city,
allowing SCP-1655 to jump from person to person,
eliminating each person’s emotional connections
until there is nothing left.
The damage could potentially cause a Broken
Masquerade scenario for the SCP Foundation.
These scenarios occur when the SCP Foundation
is unable to properly contain an anomaly and
thus, knowledge of the anomalous world becomes
public.
Among their research into SCP-1655’s biology,
yet another interesting part of SCP-1655 was
found.
It’s a female specimen and has the necessary
reproductive organs.
While this may seem mundane, this means that
SCP-1655 may have been capable of laying eggs
in the wild, implying that other members of
SCP-1655’s species may be out in the wild,
waiting to attach itself to unknowing humans
and expand their relationship-ruining reach.
Further investigation has been recommended
by the overseeing researchers.
The SCP Foundation runs into anomalies of
all shapes, sizes and danger levels.
Some anomalies may seem rather mundane, but
pose danger when put into very specific circumstances.
In the case of ticks in general, they have
been responsible for feeding on human flesh
and spreading diseases for ages.
But now, with SCP-1655 in the game it seems
that some of the species have turned to feeding
on more than just our tangible parts.
Remember earlier when I mentioned that human
connection is what allowed for humans to become
the dominant species?
Well there’s a whole lot of us humans running
around, and if there are SCP-1655 species
mating and spreading among us, it won’t
be too long until our reign in the animal
kingdom comes to a blood-sucking end.
Just when we thought losing Wifi connection
was annoying - Imagine losing all Human connection?
Yikes!
Now go check out “SCP-2031 - Ant Farm”
and “Reconstructive Maggots - SCP-726”
for more anomalies of the creepy crawly nature
from SCP Explained!